(mysterious music)
- [Narrator] It starts
with a yes or question:
Does she have a crush on me?
Will I pass the test?
Will the Mets win the World Series?
Well, they may not have
always predicted the truth.
Magic Eight balls are actually inspired
by a real life clairvoyant.
- [Narrator] Do you want
to hear your fortune?
(Greek inspired music)
- [Narrator] In the 1940s, Mary
Carter was a popular medium
best known for her mysterious
fortune-telling invention.
It was called the Syco Slate.
Essentially, a chalkboard with a cover.
When the clients would visit,
Mary would ask a question to the spirits.
(scribbling)
The room would fill with
the sound of scribbling
and then just like, poof, magic,
Mary would reveal answers
from another world
mysteriously written on the chalkboard.
Mary's son, Albert, was
inspired by his mother
and created his own truth seeking device.
But this time you didn't need a psychic
to tell you your fortune.
(big band music)
He put a pair of worded dice
inside a tube filled with molasses.
Each end was clear so you
could read the answers.
Sound familiar?
(ding)
Albert hit the streets.
He partnered with a
couple local businessmen
and opened a novelty company
where they specialized in the
Miracle Home Fortune-Teller.
After he died,
Albert's partners took over
and redesigned the project
(scribbling)
numerous times.
They ended up with crystal ball-like shape
with a die in the middle.
And a billiards company took note.
They needed a promotional item
so they replaced the crystal ball
with the iconic black eight ball.
The promotion was so
successful that they rebranded
the magic eight ball.
This time marketing it
as a fortune-telling toy.
(cash register dings)
Today, kids are still
using magic eight balls
to ask for their fortunes.
And for that,
you can thank Mary the clairvoyant.
- [Woman] Ah, yes.